there is a terrible slander being
perpetrated against liberalism and
democracy and not by you not by you but
by many people and the slander is that
liberalism and democracy is essentially
shallow and procedural and legalistic
and soulless and soulless in some way I
deny this completely based on my
understanding of liberal thinking and of
my experience in a liberal society I
regard liberal democracy as one of the
supreme achievements of the human spirit
and nothing less than that at that level
liberal democracy is not procedural it
comes with a portrait of the human being
of the person which is a portrait that
includes the person's nobility and
dignity and rights and more most
important of all of the person's
complexity liberalism is the it is the
worldview that recognizes that we live
in many realms that we are compound
beings that we are animals and angels
both and that we cannot be our identity
cannot be reduced cannot be reduced to
any one of those realms so I am a
religious man but I am a liberal I study
metaphysics I've studied metaphysics my
whole life but I am a liberal I believe
that the soul exists but I am a liberal
I do not believe that science can
account for everything in human life but
I am a liberal and I do not believe that
everything I need to know about my life
and nature can be seen with the human
eye when you were still involved with
obstacles national Bolshevism you you
claimed
whether it is a worldview that is built
on the total and radical negation of the
individual and his centrality so then
again what's your problem with the
individual so first of all if we for
example
we are working we are dealing with
liberty and the
Western
the standing of what is freedom what is
individual what is men what is right
what is subject of freedom if we change
a little bit the context for example if
we're coming for Russia and we have one
special Russian word that is called
Swoboda Swoboda that is freedom in
Russia but what is men but what does it
mean it meant identity so to be
identical to itself it's something
completely this could to be close it is
we group Swoboda it is not Western and
distending of the essence of the freedom
so if we change the context of one
civilization Western civilization to the
other we immediately we middle to
discover that shift of meaning of the
basic values of basic names for example
for us man doesn't represent individual
why we are against individualism because
individual is the part and the whole for
us the people that is holistic attitude
of Russian tradition for example for us
the people it's much more important than
individual individual is not the man so
we have different anthropology holistic
anthropology that explains our tourists
Orthodox
experience as well as Communist
know that in Western political
philosophy we have holistic conceptions
of the group we have communitarian
conceptions of the group we have anti
liberal notions of the community and the
society but my secondly who cares
nothing is right because it's nothing is
wrong because it's Western and nothing
is right because it's Russian who cares
where it comes from the question is
whether the concept that you are
presenting can be philosophically
justified and shown to be politically
fair that that is that it has some
justice attached to it I mean in I can I
can give you Hebrew words for for
freedom that mean entirely different
things who cares the important question
is whether or not we agree that human
beings are and should be free and what
should be the relationship of free
individuals to the group and what should
be the relationship of political power
to the relation between the individual
and the group
there is something there is nothing
Universal
there is nothing in the universal all
depends on the historical context on the
society on civillization I don't believe
in the unique civilization I believe in
many civilization civilization and
liberalism in the West as well well not
one of the civilization there could be
Islamic civilization with completely
different understanding of the freedom
of the human of the individual of the
right of the death death and and and
life as well Russian civilization
Chinese civilization and the problem is
now the West is experiencing
experiencing problems with its
universalism because there are five
empires
when you are the standing with what is
the man why
do not I do not subscribe to that
paradigm that was presented this morning
about the five evil empire I also think
that the MELAS that is arising that is
effecting enlightenment and freedom is
actually also breathing deeply in Europe
and we must acknowledge that that the
biggest threat to the Enlightenment
project is the right wing and the rise
of fascism within Europe itself and in
America and the notion of populist s' as
well the rise of populism so let's not
use that five evil empire as an example
to try to justify something that III
think there is a sort of a basic concept
of an understanding as a human being
whatever wherever geography may be that
I know when I am free to think when I am
free to express the thought and when I
am free to move about and if you're
trying to tell me that that is subject
to geography and subject to a certain
historical boundaries then I have a big
problem with that I didn't follow our
fine follower of France boss and our
cultural anthropology that affirmed that
any society archaic or several subu lies
has its own system and set of values and
they are incomparable there is nothing
to reverse my friend people are not
plants people have roots but they are
not only roots they also have branches
and the branches grow very far from the
roots and one of the acetyls grows as
well the growth the roots can grow I'm
not interfering with the roots I have
spent my life deep in the study of my
own tradition I have no objection to
roots but there is such a thing as hyper
rasa nation there is such a thing as too
many roots and not enough branches and
one of the things we see about the human
soul and if we see it anywhere I might
add it's in Russian literature and in
Russian poetry is that the soul is
mobile the soul moves the soul is
opportunistic spiritually as it should
be it needs to be it finds its
nourishment wherever it is this cult of
origins and roots is an insult to the
potentiality of the soul moreover it is
possible it is possible to acquire to
feel love and loyalty for something that
is not something that one is inherited
I'll give you an example I just read
I'll give you just read a very moving
thing you will recall that in Vietnam
last week our president my president for
which I apologise to all of you
my president my presidents told in in
Danang he turned to the people at the
g20 or whatever gee it was and said you
should love home he quoted The Wizard of
Oz right and either you know you you go
go home love your home be with your home
and the same week he said that a book
appeared in the United States by a
remarkable man called Chi zircon kai
zircon is the Pakistani American who at
the Democratic convention pulled the
Constitution out of his pocket and at
the end of this book I read a sentence
that stuck with me for this reason it
goes to saying he said I am an American
American patriot because I was born here
I am an American patriot because I was
not born here and he went on to explain
that the characteristics of American
life that make him patriotic freedom
liberty you know you pick any one you
want were not the case in Pakistan the
country of his youth and so what he
managed to do was travel from one
particular ism to another and to base
his patriotism on universal principles
on universal principles because
otherwise we would all be trapped within
these bubbles of ours and we could not
have a coherent conversation
for the first time I am Abraham Lincoln
said we all we all vote for liberty but
by my brother said by the same word we
don't mean the same thing and then a
century later I saw how Berlin says he
shocked other liberal
liberal theorists by claiming that human
values are irredeemably diverse and they
come under two headings positive Liberty
freedom to need a prescribed form of
life and negative freedom that I'm free
to the degree to which no individual or
group interferes with my liberties and
it seems to me that a lot of this
distinction being positive and negative
Liberty is really at the core we're
talking about the term
particularly what what you have just
been saying it's negative because it
opens the room space for everybody to
make up his own mind about what they
want to do which way they want to to go
accept and that's why that's that's why
people who do not believe in the same
values as we mostly believe in label
democracies are perfectly free to
exercise their own beliefs in even in
our democracy which is not the case the
other way round let's you could even go
further let's say two or three kind
words about Liberty from Liberty from
religious persecution I'm for it Liberty
from censorship I'm for it Liberty from
compelled religious observance I'm for
it Liberty from racial prejudice I'm for
word there are all kinds Liberty from is
the beginning of Liberty for and freedom
is only the beginning of the story of
human liberation it's not the end there
are many many things that can be done
with freedom and many bad things can be
done with freedom including I'm sure
some of the things you do every time you
write a book just kidding
Liberty from it has very concrete
definition Liberty from collective
identity the all the all the history of
liberation from collective collective
identity that was from church for
religious identity national identity
gender identity it's not while you wait
but then why would you identify
collective identity with coercion I tell
you that it's a it's it's emancipation
from coercion and that coercion is not
the same thing as collective identity
god forbid it should be the same thing
as collective identity and that it's a
very repressive and authoritarian
conception of collective identity to
insist that in order for collective
identity to be authentic and unintel
we cannot be in any way emancipated from
what emancipation from coercion of
humankind is the last point of
liberation and now where we are going
the last step of this liberal liberalism
liberation going from
having ensuring identity human identity
which the next step will be the mission
on come on cyborg and that cyber oh
that's what I say we have lost all the
links with collective identity including
in the gender and the optional gender
optional religion optional nation
optional society optional motherland
optional and after that the last step
and that is the mosque serious
challenge of liberalism I think that we
experience now the last step will be a
human optional so you could be human but
you could choose not to be human because
human is coercion so human a human kind
is a kind of collective identity this
oblige so that is transhumanism that is
instead for example now a gender
politics after that robot politics
because the robots are individuals and
they should be
rights this is dialectical
unmaterialistic
you